I feel so young at heart but I want to
grow up because it's not overrated and I
feel calmer and better every day you're
doing it the best way possible and
that's how I see you like you're yeah
I'm I will say this I feel like when you
run out and enjoy the rain and I look at
that and I'm like man I'd be like oh my
shirt's gonna get wet my boobs are gonna
look weird in my bra my hair is going to
become frizzy you'll see how thin it is
you know I'm like you know what I mean
like I I'm so neurotic but then I look
at my my kids and it'd be great for them
to have that Joy of Eve you know and I'm
the most uptight person I'm my my
parents children like you know they were
like immigrants who just wanted to play
by the rules and I really encapsulate
you know I really inherited that and so
I'm I'm I think I'm trying to do the
same thing stay youthful whatever youth
I had as a child and you know have
capture that as I get older